each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
it's my pleasure to have Martin Saltzman
here he is currently a assistant
professor at the university of singapore
national university of singapore he's
got his PhD at Yale from with Paul Hudak
and he's had some stints in Australia
and various places of the world out of
the world and so it's a great pleasure
to have him here and we'll learn about
algebraic data types it's good Thanks
monitor all right actually I'm in town
for four flock so yesterday there was a
workshop on programming languages week
program verification but it was for toy
functional languages and my talk is
actually about the new concept called
generalized algebraic gear types and
it's in the context of hassle you know
so not the real world which I thought
today my gave me this introduction to
spec sharp was really interesting ok so
what gonna wanna do so gee the jeans I'm
not sure it's a short form for
generalized algebraic dear types you
might hurt have heard from them and they
actually a very old concept I mean for
instance one I would say well I know
them a long time because he has been
using some is similar in fault and they
have a long history in depends type
communities and so on so they're not
really a new concept but actually they
found their way now in in some languages
like Haskell okay and I think maybe also
soon in in ml and the point of them is
simply they provide the ordinary
programmer with the enough power to
state very very expressive program
properties him so in the first part of
my talk I just take a look at a few
examples of of GE TS ok and then in the
second part are looking to type
inference it's always fun of my hobbies
type inference so I believe it's good to
automatically infer types which are
imposed by program text and four in the
millinery we know that
the type in front is all incomplete but
it turns out that actually fortunate
inference it's called a totally
different game then I'll look into how
to translate ght system f so the
standard technique in languages like
let's say Haskell or in compilers like
GHz is that we have to see Lee Miller
style source language which should be
translated to to a system f and of
course the question is now charities are
an extension to the system if and what
does this mean to do the source language
okay can we still use system f or do we
have to extend system if all right so
here is actually a classic example and I
am just for us how many of you actually
know high school with just so pretty
much everybody I'm but hoes so
effectively is a specification of an
algebraic dear type so we have here a a
data type expression of a and you have a
bunch of constructors like the several
constructor which represents the 0 if
the successor constructor which takes an
expression gives us a new expression we
have the plastic on structure
constructor then we have fun which
builds a function we have application
which takes a function in argument and
we have lift which effectively owes us
to lift variables to the expression
language so the technical thing is he
actually using high order abstract
syntax which you might also not know but
the interesting thing here is that this
is not quite a classic algebraic data
type because if you look at the the
types of the constructors written 0s
type expression of int and if you look
at say at the function it has expression
of a function type B goes to C okay and
usually the condition we have for
algebraic data types is that the the
types of the data types must be the same
okay so there's something strange going
on that's actually the power of these
generalized algebraic the archives now
what we can do with them is effectively
what I've been doing here with this
little GLG for expressions I've been
encoding a simple language that I
a simple type of the type system and all
right i'm doing is here i'm writing a
little evaluator maybe for a moment you
just ignore the type of notation because
the definition here is just what you
expect if i evaluate 0 i evaluate to
actually the serial number if i evaluate
the successor I availably firstly the
expression here and then I simply add 1
if I if I have a function what I'll do
is I actually create a function of using
it hi old abstract syntax effectively a
lift the the the variable X into the
expression language and apply f to that
to that expression if I have application
what I'll do is I evaluate the the d
function and evaluate the argument and I
simply apply that result as as we expect
ok 44 a very simple big step style
interpreter now an interesting thing is
affecting the type in rotation because
that type of notation state something
very curious about our of expression
language it simply says an expression of
type a evaluates to a value of typing ok
so dudaev you would actually say this
should not be valid typed because it
means for any a and it seems to break
here the right hand side of the first
Clause where we actually return an
integer ok and let's actually the trick
of these generalized algebraic data
types because when i do the pattern
matching over 0 in fact i'm not saying
anymore it's for any a it's actually the
a where the a is bound by int that's up
there ok the effectively it's some sort
of type case so we do some sort of type
case depending on the Deconstructor ok
and of course the nice thing is now we
can state much stronger properties about
our programs so that's it's a really
nice thing ok roughly what we how we
could describe these charities is some
sort of boxed existential type with
equality guard so I just was
highlighting here again the two
constructors which do not share the same
type so 0 has a type expression of
integer
and the function constructor has the
type expression of P goes to see here
now if you would actually write down
explicitly the type of disk instructor
you see what i mean by existential types
with basic Foley guards him because for
instance in this case here we have here
the Equality guard that a is nothing
else in a function for b2c and also we
see that in fact the B and the C do not
actually appear in the in the the output
type so that's why we in fact called is
actually an existential type okay
alright so roughly that's the fact now
how we could describe these charities
okay now as I said with these charities
what we can do in fact this you can in
this case we simply encode the typing
rules of a very lot of simply typed
language effectively that's what I'm
doing so the constructor is effectively
a proof you know so if you think about
it the 0 constructor just says well I'm
an int then the function constructor
says but i simply i take a function and
the application constructor simply says
I take my function argument and sorry I
take my function and I take my argument
and I give you back actually an
expression okay that's just a neat very
in fact how to encode in this case
typing route via charities alright so
let's come back to the issue what I said
before that if you look at the actual
definition of the eval function which is
nothing else in a big step interpreter I
would say it's just a natural definition
okay but we have to convince ourselves
that this is meant to type check okay
because from in the middle we know if I
if I write a polymorphic type scheme
this will definitely be a contradiction
because I say here for any a i return an
a but in this case is of course 0 is of
type int into contradiction the point is
here when I do the parametric over the 0
to highlight it here he in fact used is
equality cards okay so they're not that
explicit in actually d the extra charity
syntax in CHC but they are there because
effectively it means really the a is
constrained by
okay the fact when you're going to type
here the right hand side when we did the
pattern matching we do know that a is
actually int okay and of course we can
use this type informational to change
the type okay because we know that 0 is
an integer we have the the assumption
that a is an int and that's why I can
simply change the type of 0 to a okay so
that's why this is perfectly Val typed
now again the tricky point is of course
you would say that i equals int doesn't
float all you know it doesn't poison the
other branches yeah the mint it's only
available when we do the pattern
matching / 0 on the right hand side of
the first Clause here and effectively
that's what how would the type checking
works here for all the different clauses
yeah just like a rough rough over here
or this roofs now there's even a a
recent paper by i think andrew kennedy
and i think it's i forgot the second
author they were also adding something
similar to c sharp so effectively the
same concept of GED cheese okay and it's
quite interesting so if in fact any form
of if you have any form of algebraic
data types you can generalize this form
by effectively constraining the
constructors by equality gods okay and
really the main gag is here they can be
that he can't take advantage of these
equality guards and then be going to
type type a function maybe we blew the
parametric all right so this actually is
a classic example because most papers
are almost all papers on charities
you'll find it so this is really over
using it but i'll show you a bit more
now i was making the point that with
this charity's we can state well
effectively what we can do is we can
type more programs I mean that's what
I've been showing you here okay we
couldn't have typed this program without
gt's because simply that type
annotations would be effectively a two
polymorphic you know in classic in the
Miller but it works the GDD typing rules
now what I want to also show is in fact
that we can actually use GTS for our
program verification yeah and the cool
thing is but you already saw before we
can actually use cheat
used to to to capture proof systems okay
so here's a again a very simple and very
classic example effective what I'm doing
is here i have here at a GD t some which
takes three parameters a B and C and
effective what I'm doing is here I code
here summation that means some ABC
encodes the property that that a plus B
equals C okay there is actually
something which are left out on these
slides I'm actually using here singleton
types to represent numbers okay actually
listed on the slide so effectively what
I can do in the language like SQL in
most language I can introduce a type
which is single like data sea is just
like a singleton type which represents
zero and data s of a simply is a single
type that references the successor
that's in fact how I eco here numbers
okay so if it would use that GT here
effectively we'll be doing is here beer
representing proofs that capture the
fact that some of a plus B equals C you
know so the action would be the base
axiom that we know that if i add 0 to n
EI we know it remains the a-ok effective
retin that's an axiom okay and if you do
know that a plus B equals C then we
infect to the induction step then we do
know that the success of a plus B equals
the success of C okay effectively this
is a down card version of the piano
axioms just for for natural numbers all
right and if I look then at the term
that a value like step of step of base
effectively it represents a proof for
the property that success of successor
of 0 plus a is nothing else in the
successor of successor of a okay means
if i add any to to any number i get but
that number plus to him all right okay
so what I'm current can do now is now I
i can use this chi that is this true
two against eight stronger properties
about my programs okay so here is now
the append function which is now written
in the Haskell style language so what
does a pen do it simply takes two lists
adjust the pen stem yeah so if you
ignore here the first argument for a
moment it's just the typical inductive
definition what you expect so if i
append mel with with anything else the
list of wise then i get back wise if I
see a non-empty list what i'll do is i
append the tail to the wise and then of
course I I add icons the first element
to that result in use ok that's the
obvious de standard inductive definition
of a pent so what I do it differently or
in addition here is I'm using a year my
my GT that represent to prove that a
plus B equals C and i'm also using our
refinement again a charity that states a
stronger property board list ok so i'm
not only stating that my list has fallen
ill with empty and it has a cons which
takes an element and the tail but also
i'm having here a somewhat additional
parameter n that keeps track of the
length of the list okay because in this
case what I'm having here is that little
of course we know it's a list of length
0 if I have cons I do know that the tail
list has some length m and of course if
it wants anything to that list I get a
linked list of length success of him ok
now what i'm doing here is no I passing
in additionally the proof that L plus M
equals N and what I'm standing here is
know that if i append two lists i do
know that the length of the output list
is nothing else than the sum of the
equalists ok this is in fact now
effectively programming with proofs ok
so I really know passing the proof that
L plus M equals ten and I take use of
that fact but it's in this case it's
very crucial that i have here the base
case because of course in this case i do
know that L is actually equal to 0 ok
and of course in this case I would again
get the contradiction in
because I claim wise is a list of length
m and the output little is actually of
length n but of course if I heavier the
perimeter of the base case I actually do
know that if l is equal to 0 m is equal
to n it was written up here ok all right
so effectively but this show is not
acidities you have in fact a way to add
proof through your program ok and state
such stronger properties ok all right so
of course now we could go ahead and and
look at lot of let's say in this case
functions that manipulate lists Korea
have maybe the half function which
dropped every second element from from
from a list him ignore the question
marks i mean the definition of the half
one which would be straightforward if if
my list is empty half of an empty list
is empty if i have half of a list with
at least two elements what i'll do is i
take half of that a list drop the second
element and and then let my final result
okay now what I would like to state of
course is that I would like to use now
my GT my proof the state of course that
the length of the output list is is
indeed just half the length of the input
list ok so what I want to say is in fact
here that I know that M plus M equals n
which just has the half property now the
funny thing is in fact now this what I
want to show is here this show is here a
kind of weakness of these charities
because this representation of summation
is not strong enough because the problem
here is we cannot prove that if M plus M
equals 0 it implies M equals 0 ok what
be effectively would need for for the
first case ok and in the second case in
fact we need the property that if M plus
M equals n plus 2 sorry this actually
means implication ok so what it means in
fact there is it means that they exist M
such that M is M prime plus 1 and we do
know that M prime plus M prime equals M
ok that's the property I would need to
verify that it for a second close ok so
it's just not strong enough here of
course what i can do is now as I said I
can always invent new proof systems I
could just no use a special purpose
proof system which which encodes the
half property yes so the Sun yeah I get
back to this done that's
effectively here we have here a special
proof system that encodes the half
property this GT is nothing else
whatever it was just saying here okay
and just you know that proof the proof
system in fact to verify that that half
function really takes away half of the
elements yeah now it's a bit annoying
that if I if I use of this cheetah
cheese i sometimes can't use you know my
basic axioms I have I mean usually if
you think about if we reason about
natural numbers we have all played piano
exams and average actually everything
actually should follow from the piano
axiom okay but it seems to hear i have
to actually always use some special
proof systems okay now in fact me what
you'd like to do is in fact to to
specify a lemma that says that the sum
of is actually a type sorry that the sum
of m plus m equals n then of course it
implies that we can all go to get
approve of the half property okay now
this is of course what I'm pointing out
here is a bit of criticism of
opportunities okay because they're very
cool we can program with proofs but they
don't give us everything for free
because here I really would like to have
maybe a fear pool with tactics okay
effectively what I need to do is here I
have to prove this lemma by hand doing
induction I think we have to write a
program which represents the proof for
that little Emma and even I was trying
it okay i was actually trust trying it
yesterday still jetlagged and ten hours
ahead or so so i didn't quite could
figure it out but just too tedious you
know i mean i think it's possible okay
but it's it's really clumsy okay so the
point is he really that this is actually
strictly something which should come for
free from from approve assistant okay so
this is just now a little bit a short
summary of what Gigi's are about so as I
said day the nothing really novel you
know so they have a long history in in
the dependent types community and I
think the novelty is just that for the
ordinary programmer like that has the
program cannot program with proofs I
mean like programming with proof was
always something which was just
exclusive to let's say people were using
or so but it's really know the
ordinary program
okay as I said I was telling you this in
the context of our high school style
language but any sort of language that
support algebraic data types you could
generalize them and I think even if you
would use the extension of andrew
kennedy and i think yeah i've forgotten
it's Chloe Russell you could effectively
do the same in that extension of C sharp
okay now the good thing is of course we
can know as the ordinary programmer we
can now stay properties for which we
actually used to have a external probe
assistant like or elf elf and 12
okay and that's of course often very
annoying if I have to switch to an
external proof assistant to make my
proof it's much more convenient if I can
stay in the same environment I can use
the same language I write programs also
to specify proofs that's quite neat but
what I was saying on the others on the
previous slide before it's still
non-trivial to reason about gdt proofs
you know what I was showing you with the
ex realization of some I would actually
have to provide lemma to get it to get
to the Exim for half and that's in fact
still too tedious if I have to do it
each time myself because I really want
to have a proven system with tactics
that maybe assists me here okay so this
is actually pretty much the the first
third of my talk just a bit of me and
use the concept of opportunities now
when we talk about Hinda million
languages we usually care about
inference okay so a language like like
has to support actually type inference
and we would like to say no do we get
properties like completely sore
decidability okay so next question will
be is actually chilly the type inference
complete okay and of course for any
language something like any compiler
even for in indy ml bold its these days
well established we going to use a typed
in the mid language and as a standard we
use these days system f okay so the
question is then how do we actually
translate UT System F so at this point i
want to say because when i talk about
hot influence actually it's proven
already by myself and independently also
by Cheney Hintze and party that the GDD
type checking is decidable that means if
I provide the annotation it's actually
decidable okay actually the
the bad news is ok I have to imagine I'm
an academic so I live with contrived
example 2 is actually a contrived
example that fools for the first time
that she did the infant is incomplete
and decidable let's really a shock you
know cause usually we are used to if you
remain in the hill the middle of
fragment and even if they had extensions
you know I mean there were a lot of
extensions added to him in over time
like I mean ok Ezra biotypes box
existential types records and so on and
usually always we could retain the nice
properties like completely as a
principal types yeah but here is now a
totally contrived TV program that shows
you that that function f here can be
given an infinite set of maximal types
ok what is the maximal type is simply a
type for which one there is no more
general type ok the effectively all
these types ok I'm not gonna go through
a dieta because it's just too tedious
because i didn't really formally just
tell you the GD typing rules you know if
you don't trust me that these are barely
types you can do this offline you know
it's just you know it's it just shows
you all these types actually are valid
and none of them is is it smaller than
the other so they're all incomparable
and here's another one ok so so that's
actually one i've also used later okay
we will i mean at this point i'm not
going to tell you but i will tell you
later why these types are correct ok the
puzzling thing actually is the puzzling
thing is maybe that we suddenly have
some character you know in the output
type so if you look at that function or
what it does it takes x and y ok and and
on the left hand side icons X to Y so
the Colin actually is the cons operation
in in in in Haskell yeah so X Colin why
is nothing else in the cons so we would
definitely expect that we get back a
list ok and most likely i think you
would intuitively say that this is the
correct type because what you would
expect is here that we have here X has
type T of X and because icons X to Y
that means y must be a list of T of X
okay and somehow that third parameters
that doesn't really matter here you know
I even though don't don't have a
variable I mean that only appears in the
type you know so obviously this would be
definitely the intuitive type I would
say but strangely enough you get also
all these types okay and of course the
thing is the tricky point is here
because of these gnocchi's when I do the
pattern matching over the K I do
actually know that the set is actually a
character okay so if I would have just
written work of X Y and written zet okay
not character then this would be the
only type okay but because i have
written f of X Y and character I do not
gonna do the pattern match I actually
have this this equality guard that says
that equals a character okay a none of
this assumption of course I can do some
real thing and we'll look into this
later why we actually end up with all
these types okay but of course it's a
devastating news you know it's it shows
that of course in practice it won't
happen you know if with all
counterexample they they will only
appear for contrived I mean sorry these
problems only appear for for contrived
counter examples so okay that does some
further bad news okay from Hinda Miller
we do know that if you have a principal
type derivation we do know that all the
sub duration our principal they actually
this is the the critical point to
establish complete ease of algorithm w
okay that's the key point to to verify
that now Sheila tease do not enjoy this
property here so the the the previous
example begun investigating examine in
detail okay so I fear I would run out of
time if I go through this example in
detail so we'll discuss is offline so
roughly the intuition is here actually
that here that function G has the
principal type list the list of lists of
character okay but strangely enough that
F in fact can be given one of the maxima
types which we have seen before okay
effectively this breaks the property
that
which you know from in the Mariner that
if you have a principal typing
derivation or the sub duration must be
printed okay so I just skip over that
and we looking now at a previous works
on on trinity type in front okay so how
can we affect now maybe restore some
sort of the nice properties so that's
one of attempt that was by simone a and
podium and effectively the ideas now
that we obtain complete type inference
by enlarging the set of expressible
types ok so again that i just want to
show you some funny type and we'll see
later where this funny type is coming
from so that funny type usually is funny
because we're using here a implication
among equations so usually for Milla
Milla we are used to that the
constraints that appear in type schemes
must be conjunction of constraints okay
but here in fact what we do have is here
an implication the effectively this is
the literate construction read by the
gahe and we just take this as the the
type so in fact this is a complete type
but first the trouble is types become
unreadable I don't want to present this
type 2 2 a 2 a user and there's a more
serious issue that actually have a non
elementary complexity of the inference
of us okay the problem is simply it turn
anymore just solving of of equation
constraints but you have to solve is
very very complicated implication
constraints and then we have non
elementary complexity okay so recently
they actually you know to competitive
approaches one is by paid insurance and
some colleagues and the others by podium
and one of these students and put it
says I want to stratify the problem okay
as I audit before if you have a
completely fully annotated program the
type checking part is is it's completely
decidable okay so we do know that in
this case we do get the nice properties
but of course nobody wants to a only
program with such programs because there
are too many invitations you know I mean
as much as possible would like to
relieve the user for the burden of
annotating the program with with the
right annotations okay now why they call
it sir if I type inference essay for the
fragment
we have complete annotations we know we
get completely decidability okay but
what we want to do is maybe having I'm
some ristic you know in fact is a
programmer is not willing to complete
annotated program and what they're
having is here having someone some
heuristics to infer missing annotation
giving a partially annotated program
okay so this is of course somehow an
approach that gives up on on in front
you know because it's in a holistic
sorry it gives up on deterministic
difference you know you're not sure
whether your program sorry that holistic
will actually succeed or not you know
it's not a very nice property and even
worse is that that even is not stable
that means if you have a program and for
which is artistic actually could succeed
and put in further missing invitations
strangely enough if you add more
annotations which are all correct that
aroostook might not succeed anymore okay
it's a very strange spent property what
is it actually is implemented in GHC is
something a little bit between these
arista canned a completely fully
annotated program is called Bobby type
inference so the idea is in fact now
that you can only use these refinements
that means these these equality guards
if actually the function has been
annotated okay so its effect a
compromise so if i have my eval function
from before with the type annotated the
g d's geez come into action okay
otherwise not okay again some reasonable
programs are rejected and the whole
system is not stable if we provide more
more annotations okay so what I'm doing
is now here is I show you what I've done
with with two colleagues and this is
something which is a total novel
inference approach okay because what you
expect is that it's something not any
more standard in the middle okay be
having your problem where yes i'm
getting equally inference and by sorry
we're getting a program an innocent
program with an infinite number of
Maximo types okay so they have to some
more tame the system
effectively is we have to tame the type
system in such a way that we that we can
rule out non sensible types or solutions
ok so here I equate often when you know
from him Lee Miller to compute the type
who actually compute the solution to a
unification okay but of course here we
can't anymore use the standard serving
algorithm which we know from Finland
wilner like unification and what I'm
showing you is in fact is a problem that
we can do it with something which is
called her plant constraint abduction
okay subduction is something which has
some long history by some philosopher
peers and the basic idea is we have to
infer the missing effect okay all right
so yeah yeah so in the previous examples
when you had the standard set of maximal
types but but all but one of the more
nonsensical yes highly noticeable I get
to this point because i was actually i
was already telling you too much and
take at this stage yeah so but in
general all but one would be nonsense
yeah i will tell you ain't like why i
would claim that their nonsense okay so
now we looking at that that problem
which we briefly observed by looking at
the auto example more detail okay this
is the example from before where I try
to convince you that a reasonable type
or a sensible type for this program
would be because we have X as a type T
of X and V cons X to Y I would expect
that why has a type list of T of X ok
that was the sensible type but we have
to in fact realize that the typing what
we do is we type on the temporary
assumption okay so I'm doing our a bit
of a big step I not showing you in fact
the typing rules i'm showing you
actually here now a formula which
represents the typing rule ok so that's
in fact an abstraction so and the
promise here as i said when we do for
instance a type before Henry Miller we
do know all the formula we need only
conjunction of of equations okay but of
course here when we do the pattern
matching over a charity that equality
guard is only low let's say locally
visible
so that means the formula we do actually
need here are implications here
effectively this means under the
temporary assumption that the type of
set tea set equals char be going to type
the right-hand side ok so this is your
the symbol for for implication ok and
the right hand side demands of course
that the type of y must be a list of
excess him now you hopefully so
effectively you can argue note here that
the left hand side are the constraints
writing from the GD pattern match and
the right hand side constrains us
nothing else in the standard he lamented
constrain him and of course the left
hand side constraints and implication is
another part that the gdt part ok um
sorry maybe we look again why we have
all these funny types and of course and
you see here i can now type this under
this temporary assumption that's why i
get all these funny types from before ok
and what I will argue later is that we
have to change the system ok and for
that in fact I ended users this context
this is this context a concept so called
parent constraint abduction ok because
from in the milliner we're used to that
the only solve equations conjunction of
equation that's actually is also called
the her point constraint domain ok so
here in fact now we have to solve these
implication constraints so of course
what we try to do this here the
solutions which we want to accept our
only those which we know from Hindley
Milner the urban constraint domain
because previously I was making the
point that the work by simulating
portugee actually was recovering in fact
complete type inference by a lodging
descent of expressible types in the
sense that the formula we need to
express the typing problems also the
formula we accept in our type system but
that's not what we want to do is just
becoming not any more tractable ok and
the types become an unreadable all right
now what I'm trying to do is now here is
I first argue that all these solutions
which is often before which correspond
to these infinite set of types are
indeed solutions ok by solutions I
simply mean
that even these guys actually imply that
implication constraint I simply use the
standard law that if I've a formula C 1
implies another formula C 2 implies C 3
I can pull out the implication and build
a conjunction that means the swords if
and only if c1 and c2 implies C 3 okay
so that means if I want to verify that
this is indeed a solution okay yes hey y
DX must be a list of TZ
that so you first say so this is
actually from the in the Miller you know
x.x cons why tells me that t y must be a
list of TX yes but i'll see you at is
ethically the type of jet is it the tea
set is where it comes from the chile de
para match remember unrelated to you
after exactly exactly and this is look
this is a contrived example it's
actually two totally unrelated but in
your next slide you say t x equals and
then list of TZ yes yes but but why is
it it's like now you relate them yes but
i'm just trying to verify that these are
indeed solutions you know i only know
the name Oh saying if they were to be
between ladies yes still okay so right
so I'm just trying to argue that the
types of before you know sorry here okay
I should have repeated the type
annotation what I'm trying to do is now
is this that these types they must come
from some solutions okay and I'm no only
briefly argued why this is actually
these are belly types and I'm arguing
always they come from from these
solutions and now here on that slide I'm
not verifying that these solutions which
correspond to these types are all okay
they are actually indeed solutions and I
simply applying that law and I simply
cannot easily verify that that this is
actually trivalent to debt I mean I'm
not going to go through your detailed
you can just easily verify that formula
okay effectively it shows now of course
somehow the tea set is totally unrelated
to the to the tee Y and the T of X you
know but that's kind of a strange thing
and that's why we get all these too many
solutions effectively now what would be
a sensible way to to tame the system
because as I said here we have the
problem that we have too many solutions
here so in order to to to recover a
completeness okay or even maybe
decidability they have to take the type
system we should throw away solutions
okay because we have your too many
solutions so the hope is of course if we
find the sensible restrictions we do
know that the the Mets
solutions we find they become actually
finite ok now I'm arguing now that the
type because often before and again i'm
sorry i didn't really repeat that so
it's here so here that type from before
I'm arguing oh it's a sensible type okay
and I'm trying to argue this in terms of
of this type they're coming from a
solution okay and I'm ugh you know that
that solution is sensible ok so I'm
arguing the solution is sensible because
it can be concluded from the left-hand
side and the right hand side here
remember the left-hand side are the
Equality guards from the GG pattern
matches and the right-hand sides are the
hindi muna typing constraint so their
fatigue set equals jar implies T why is
the list of TXS ya know the argument is
here t of y equals G of X is of course
clearly a solution here I help you agree
but additionally then the nice property
is we can conclude that solution if you
just build the conjunction of the
left-hand side and the right hand side
ok that's definitely not stronger and
the intuition is here now that we're not
inventing anything ever betray it was
already there in the program effectively
the program contains all the information
but does d solutions which are in fact
these the ones which are which stood us
up the ones which are this infinite
number of maximal solution they're not
sensible because he cannot follow them
from the left hand side on the right
hand side ok because they days that
which is average or a connection between
in fact here's a typo so it should be t
he said sorry they establish this
arbitrary connection between between t
ZT x and t y okay all right now and this
is now the main the main idea of that
method I was developing a forgot to
mention this before is together with
peter stocky and tom Shrivers this is
not a method the main idea how to all we
want to tame that that she did the type
system because if you can now throw away
all the solutions which cannot be
concluded
from the left hand side on the
right-hand side we can actually learn in
a nice result that says that all these
solutions and we get must be finite okay
and of course sorry all the maximum is
not finite and of course if they have a
finite set of maximum solution at least
we can recover we can rock we can
recover completely decidability okay so
we cannot recover a principal types in
general yeah but these completing this
are the building can be recovered sorry
yeah okay sure it's just the terminology
okay but if you have an infinite set I
mean that doesn't doesn't doesn't make
sense okay so you have I have a
contrived example okay we're just play
through the algorithm okay and this is
just the contractile girl a program
where I have a cheetah t and i have two
clauses biped amend the B and in the the
first Clause I constrained the type of X
to the end and in the second Clause I
constrained the type of of X to be
boolean okay so typing rice I can
express the typing property of this
program in terms of these implication
constraint okay I also didn't really I
only glanced over this I mean I'll
Jennifer take it by faith that this is a
is a faithful full and faithful
abstraction of the typing properties it
can also be for approval okay I'll give
a later reference now the idea is now
how to how to perform inference via this
constraint of action method is you
simply for each individual branch what
we'll do is you simply compute the
sensible solutions okay and of course we
here in this case we don't look at the
maximal ones so the set we only look at
the solutions which can be concluded
from the left hand side controlled with
the right hand side if i take equals in
and she puts int i can actually conclude
t equals a and T equals int okay and in
fact both our bar are indeed a awesome
solution so I call them sensible okay
and similarly for the the second branch
I do the same thing okay again there is
actual algorithm which does it for me
know that means if I hyper base
implication I can apply an algorithm
that gives me the finite set of sensible
maximal solutions okay now of course i
have yet to something you know because i
have to
create a solution for the overall prop
problem and the idea is simply here is
that we simply test all combinations now
this is just a pool fourth method so
each of the branches gives us a finite
set of maximal solution to get a
solution to the overall a typing problem
we just test all combinations if we just
test all the combinations we have and of
course you already see that only this
one this combination is actually one
which is a valid candidate and sorry
ballot in a sense is also a maximal
maximal solution okay so that means
based on that principle for that
contrived program we we get that this
function f has a principal type B of T
goes to 18 ok remember it is this type
is only principle if we throw away the
non sensible solution ok all right and
of course the nice thing is we can
recover some sort of inference for
instance none of the other approaches
what I mentioned before would be able to
infer the type program ok all right so
you would say this is totally contrived
because you've only seen contrived
examples before amid ago what is the
still aboard abduction if I only can
improve the inference for for contrived
program is it worth while the effort you
know maybe that he got one before a
theoretician it's definitely worth fault
ok but actually it has it has a more
more implications I feel ok and the main
point yeah so if you do is you get more
than one maximal ended yeah they could
just at least require a dead pointing to
type annotation that
we're only one of the that makes more
candidates are an instance sure you can
do all the analysis actually I'm getting
to this point so maybe not sure whether
you mean what i want to say but we will
give you a much better description
where'd I meditators i miss yes exactly
but even he in fact I shall making a
different point now maybe the orbital
always been reversible there yeah
understeer but in fact here the point I
don't even want to make is that this
this inference via abduction method is
even useful for type error diagnosis
here because of course before I I was
only showing with these these contrived
examples where I can improve over over
existing approaches for him now here i
show you know the example from before
where i was using the some charity to
prove that the append function actually
or that the length of the output list is
actually the sum of the two input list
and i was actually making a mistake you
know if you look at the first clause I
if you ignore the first proof term
parameter appending nil and wise should
give me little it should be wise okay so
that's definitely a programming mistake
now the thing is that we can actually
use this inference via abduction method
to precisely explain why this shouldn't
type check okay because here if you look
at the the first Clause again if you do
the the type of structure to the
implication constraint it would follow
it would yield the following implication
constraints s for any l m n and actually
that's no a is a typo so that means prop
that for any LM and n and I of course
simplified it if M equals n + l equals
that then we must conclude that n is
equal to Z ok which is of course clearly
not the case ok but the trick is you
know this is of course a proof or sorry
this is an incorrect statement ok but
now we can i infect use abduction to to
come up with if they may be correct
proof ok because if it would you if it
would know in fact if you apply that
method you if we ignore the the
quantifiers we in fact find that m equal
set would be
the solution yeah if we take here M
equals n le pizzette and N equals that
then we in fact can conclude that m
equal set is actually a sensible
solution yeah now you can use this
either to provide a concise type error
message okay this is really useful I
think or even you could do in fact do
you can even insert a runtime check
because the fact that we return the
middle doesn't mean that that program
always will fail it actually it is only
technically incorrect if you look at a
type annotation if the second input list
is empty you know and that that's
effectively what the sensible solution
stands for you know so we could actually
turn it into a runtime check so also
this has actually some relations to work
on proof repair because there are people
working on on trying to repair proofs by
using abduction and in fact here again
I'm just using now trying to use
abduction to to repair a you type
program effectively okay so that's that
would be also possible application all
right so the the the the second third of
my talk to short summary gitu type if
it's just a hard problem so we we cannot
we cannot hope to accept all through our
programs and and and obtain complete
type inference so one possible solution
where I was showing you here is actually
we just rule out nonsensical solution I
mean that's actually a classic a classic
approach if there are too many solutions
the system is too powerful we just have
to throw based solutions okay this is
actually written up in the paper with
Tom Travis and Peter sucking it can find
on my hope that on my on my home page
okay so in the the second part but I
want to briefly show you is how we
actually can translate it yes
do the
when you rule out all these nonsensical
solutions does that correspond at all to
syntactic constraints you can put on
program definitions on the program
definitions to that would you know rule
out those nonsensical solutions in the
first place like for instance that
contrived example it seems you're
introducing a tight that's not actually
constraining anything they used yes of
course i mean i don't okay in real
programs let's say that use GD tease i
couldn't find a program which has an
internet set of maximal types so it's it
all seems to work smoothly so it's at
this stage it's just an academic an
academic problem but i just want to
point out that that technique of
influence via her parent constraint
abduction and looking at sensible
solution is actually useful for or for
proof repair okay effectively it's it's
something which which allows you to
solve an academic problem but also I
think it has practical consequence it's
really useful so yeah so will the long
compositionality or what non stability
of the girl gorillas lloyds exit by
definition stable and compositional when
i restrict myself to the center the
solution it's also 111 trick i play
because i really tame the system such
that it's really bad definition
compositional so means that this will be
huge improvements if he would have it of
course it's a big and so the
compositionality and stability is a big
thing that makes the moment really hard
no definitely so but as i said i mean i
don't have strong arguments to walk to
to argue with simon because i only have
these that's a contrived example where
it matters but i believe that for
typeerror diagnosis it's it's an issue
so and the problem is of course if you
look at a huge system if like tht you
try to not doing something too costly
when you actually that is only do
inference you know effectively these
current ghd solution is a cheap way out
you know to get a reasonable inference
system with a minimal amount of effort
involved so what I've been actually
showing you here is with
let's say we using implication
constraint and doing her brand
constraint abduction it really deviates
from the total standard approach how you
view in lebanon inference you know it's
totally I mean actually I've implemented
all this in comedian and stuff but it
see at the moment easily breaks under
small rewrites a very fragile that's a
real problem in practice I believe and
if you could ever time not you're right
this is not as fragile if you seem to
imply right yes I think it would be a
good argument but yeah I seen it the tip
it's a big deviation from what's there
now this is not a cheap by huh but I
mean effectively what what what what I'm
saying here is you have to start
rewriting your front end from scratch
you know you have to really throw away
everything what you have there so and
this is something which when you talk to
Simon paid insurance he is reluctant to
do you know and you're already occurring
that you'd look to drill program to use
GV g yeah and to see if they need this
or there forever you only looked at the
ones that it will finally managed to get
to work ugh yes right and so you didn't
look at all the way off try of course I
mean or enabled the problem is there's
not enough experience with that
programming feature I mean in two years
time it could say it's just not good
enough you know that that cheap solution
in GHC but I myself don't have enough
experience I have contrived example
which precisely point out the problem
and I have some reasonable examples that
say well even if this is just solving a
contrived probably even but for
typeerror diagnosis is highly useful and
this is really old something which comes
from from the proof theory where people
trying to use abduction to to to fix
proofs so okay so effectively now I
showed you achieve these examples why
they're useful okay and talked about the
charity inference and I'm looking at at
back-end issues and sorry so as I said
many compiles actually are translated to
system and it's just a classic base or
THC or Flint and so on now the first
question would be can be just naively
translate JD chistes
f do we need anything else and of course
already you you you run into trouble
because if I just throw rate is equally
guards if I lose a type reservation so
my source program which has the cheating
type system is correct but here you see
of course if I would translate this
naive it is to system f sorry actually
that's the end list of a and this
machine is actually very crucial okay
because of course and since the map it
wouldn't be Belle type because it says
for any M and M and of course it would
be something which is two polymorphic
okay so we definitely have to extend
system f somehow and abroad fourth
method would simply be well let's just
add gdt is the system f you know seems
to be the reasonable choice we have a
new language feature we just add it to
the internal language but the problem is
really that the core language is already
quite big in in in in in THC and she has
a lot of other extensions like type
classes and type functions and so on so
you really do not know where do I stop
here you know you are a type browser
system f28 type function to system f a--
so we would like really a fairly
principled system f extension which is
powerful enough to to let's say a host a
variety of of source language features
okay now what if we simply apply the
proofs or programs principles okay
because effectively you think about it
that these equality guards they allow us
to change types okay so i could just
maybe attach proof terms to to these
type equations okay and it's not only
the first initial step what I'm doing is
here I this is a first attempt I encode
a type equality by using coercion
functions casting functions I say a
equals P if I actually have a function
from A to B and from B to a okay sounds
sounds reasonable isn't it
now when I have my Machida key from
before effectively what I'm doing is I'm
compiling away all these equality guards
and are replacing effectively securities
these type equalities via this this no
value representation of of type equality
okay so in fact here base and step for
instance pace I I path here additionally
the proof that W is actually equal to Z
and I passing the proof that X equal
equal to one okay the good thing is we
just need system f here no extension I
mean system f is with the boxed
extension types okay not sure whether
you see it so technically it's really
it's possible actually to translate that
depend program to the internal form
where we effectively each time we're
using a a type equation what we'll do is
in fact be using the respective casting
function okay but it's extremely clumsy
okay and therefore sometimes really
programming ourself citizens here I need
the casting function that says if
success of a equals success of P we do
know from logic of course that a equals
B and have to program it myself ok so
the promise here there is a lot of
runtime overhead there's a technical
problem which creatures a decomposition
problem which I just skip it is not
practical you know it's it's definitely
not not not not not practical okay yeah
you could say that they carry some
quality constraints here always know
that all the gusts identities hey you
can have like the work has been done
our school
bye-bye
well I've got his name but he first made
this equality data types and they're
always high density functions discuss so
you could always yeah i erase them away
organically at the loss of all the glass
to say baseline the problem the problem
here is really it doesn't quite work
because you really I know you want to
have the new type trick you know where
you have you want to encode life is
equality that's what you're referring to
yeah you do it it's a snap right so just
assume it's they're implemented by
primitive yeah but that's not okay
effectively that's in fact what we doing
you know I just want to say this is
something which is possible but not very
principled and it's it's it's not
practical yeah so the runtime overhead
you mentioned there I mean that's really
when you can throw all the stuff away
right because you don't need to preserve
this interval but the thing is we only
just need is to preserve while typing I
mean Princeton's be okay what is the
issue here the issue is we do know if
the source program type checks we have a
stalinist result that says the the the
the back end will never crash okay but
in a tie preserving compiler may want to
preserve the types and of course the
issue is here dead system f the
intermediate stuff is not anymore Val
typed
in the compiler or yes on the crew yeah
no here hell yes oh yeah because here it
no I also maybe run the code when you
run the code because here you can you
can erase all this stuff just before you
run the code that is you of course but
it's but you have to in fact figure out
where you can erase it and these kind of
things you know so I as a set it's it's
possible in theory but in my opinion is
not practical okay so I understand what
he says when everybody i would have a
call to a cost function i dunno it
effectively evaluates the identity even
I don't bother calling it okay it's
possible but I think it it's there's
actually a much easier way okay and the
basic idea is now if you know actually I
show you for the first time that she did
you type in work okay which always was
expressing in terms of implications okay
this is in fact the type we rule which
allows us to change the type so in fact
here using as a formulation where we
have C is a set of constraints gamma is
the typing environment and are not these
two guys we can assign either type let's
say t2 okay but if we actually can can
verify the under the constraints see we
can actually prove that the type t1
equals 2 sorry i was going the wrong way
he should say the eq look at the premise
of that rule if we do know that es type
t1 and if we can conclude from the
constraint that the type t1 equals 2t to
of course then we can conclude that he
has the type t2 as well from before it
was our example where we had 0 is an
integer we knew that a equals int and
from that in fact we can conclude that
that 0 is also of taipei ok now the
tricky of what we're doing is here we
are not using now these value currents
anymore but just in fact using corrosion
zest types okay because as you argue it
we can throw them away and actually in
chin in any type of Suffolk compiler
eventually we're going to throw away all
the types okay so they are only there up
to a certain point then we can throw
away the types but we don't want to do
it at runtime you know you don't want to
do it when when we get the final
put and that's in fact now pretty much
the the new CFC internal language the
trick is here we be having all kinds
which describe type equations and we
assign types to these kind which are
type equations so effectively the
curtain is now a type and we have newer
we having a new typing rule which simply
allows us to do some sort of typecasting
that means if we can prove this would be
in the eternal language if we actually
can prove that from sea we can compute
that t1 equals t2 then it will be this
type curve C and we simply have a cast
which allows us to turn Eve it is of
type T 1 into e which is of type t2 okay
now of course this thing here this cast
here is something which we only need to
to preserve the types and eventually
what we'll do is we just throw it away
okay it's very similar how we for
instance do it with with polymorphism
when we have type application and n-type
abstraction so effectively also then in
any type of serving compiler eventually
you're going to just throw it away okay
the type so it's it's pretty much the
same thing and there's also then written
up in a paper so I won't have so much
time to talk about this yes are you sure
this only occurs in the core language
right so can't write your own
inhabitants 41 equals to teach you so I
mean the question is did
bottom always lives in t1 and t2
so you're always showing
yes no interest it's effectively it's
going to be constructive proof systems
just think about it's an equality type
proof system and I have a bunch of
initial assumptions like C and
effectively what what it's doing is
we're just applying now curry Howard and
these seas are nothing else improve
terms which represent the proof that
that t1 equals t2 and they're just
living in the type language because we
want to get rid of them I'm not sure
whether you ask this question how do you
know that your proof terms are involved
there is nobody by what about you mean
false you mean like something is for
fine well the only thing which is
undefined would be false like if I have
Endicott school so in that that would be
something which would be I can't see
that there is anything like undefined I
mean if I have false I don't need any
proof proof term you know because from
Falls I conclude anything you know if I
sorry if I have here something which
from which i can conclude falls it means
that sea itself must be inconsistent and
if she's in inconsistent I can assign
any type in order and I'm already and
remember if if C is inconsistent I will
never ever enter that that that program
code because it effectively means I
cannot build a value now because it's
inconsistent but if I can build a term c
and lastly this type that actually
doesn't terminate
right which which if you're not careful
you can okay maybe never yep you can
give it this time and instant since
you're going to raise it at runtime
you're going to skip the non terminating
part and you're going to get to the bad
case in the program
but we never evaluates see say so if
work in ml you can I can define a cast
structure from an alpha to beta pi by
making a function it says no throw
exception or run run forever okay so
take the run forever case right can you
basically give that any type of one
particular I could give it type t1
equals t2 right okay but that's that
theory of course okay that's a sound as
with all that says the theory must be
consistent it includes non termination
tests for finished Korean terms
I don't be deceived I have a very good
thing the correlation terms are built in
you cannot write their own sees no
they're really yeah exactly oh I can i
scratch yeah I I was maybe what I was
trying to say is that they have here a
type equality proof system and
effectively all what I'm saying is we we
derive the proof you know inclusion bro
yes but well you can you know you can
actually have your own courage but it
must satisfy conditions determination
yes so the language for kia the language
for C or different languages right
yes of course yes yeah look I know
you're dead yeah huge gaps you know is
just like highlights of the ideas and I
didn't tell you anything about how
Aussie Aussie actually looks like you
know so effectively it's just a very
simple language we just use use types so
when I mean we won't be evaluate anyway
so interesting things I just thought
I'll mention it this effect will be new
the new ghz core language and the funny
thing is of course you see now that we
we have a version of system f where the
attached proofs to all programs i mean
here we have a proof that that's t1
equals t2 so so so so that ght internal
language is really shifting to becoming
a almost like one of these categories of
constructions and so on so it's you can
do it and fancy things and the good
thing is of course it looks like a very
uniform system f very end which is
powerful enough to host GD cheese and
type lots and type functions though okay
anyway so i was i mean here i have an
example i just skip it because i'm
running I mean I'm all running late okay
so the main point is that these
charities they are really i think a cool
tool and as i said it's not only for toy
languages like Haskell but i think they
also are available in c-sharp and
effectively it means really programming
with with proofs okay but the important
point is you don't get it you don't get
everything for free you know because you
might still have to reason about proofs
they're just too clumsy to do it in
theory you can do it but you still might
need an external prove assistant and the
GT in front is really challenging but
that's really some hope i believe that
the idea is burger constrained abduction
really allows to specify a tractor
prototypes inference system and in
particular the type error diagnosis you
get that for free I just sketch then
also this extension of system f + type
equality corrosion I didn't mention
anything I type functions or whatever
but geez can be translated also
mentioned there are other solutions
possible like intentional type analysis
and I think you're from Nottingham and I
think
kanaa McBride with somebody else he has
even a different proposal I think
there's a huge variety of system f star
language we can choose from so I'm the
same thing would be expressed
differently oops and actually in
practice I believe that GG's are not
powerful enough because we need the
combination of thai place and type
functions but i'll be around and you
might want to ask me and i can give you
a demo of my convenience system so
that's it sorry for being 15 minutes
late